hey what's up welcome back to my channel
my name's samuel leeds
and i want to talk today about
the day i met my wife because it's the
anniversary today of when i very first
met amanda
on the 5th of april 2014 which is just
it's always a little bit of um an
emotional day for me when i remember
back to that day and i'll tell you what
happened in the moment
but also weirdly when
i met my wife and how it happened
it really really helped me out in
business because i'll tell you what
happened i'll share with you why but i
really think if you can just get this
lesson
that i'm going to share today if you can
grab the lesson it will actually help
you become
very successful in business because i
actually wasn't you know i mean when i
met my wife i was
2014 i wasn't i'm multi-millionaire i
was doing all right
i had a decent property portfolio but
let me show what happened so i was
standing at the front of the church
he's actually at a wedding and we i i
only knew the groom
okay i wasn't like a super close family
friend and
i saw amanda and i just thought she
looks
amazing she looks beautiful and i really
wanted to speak to her
however at the end of the service by the
time i was like looking to see where she
got
she left and i thought oh man
you know i'll probably never see her
again i i connected eyes with her at the
at the church um and i thought i need to
see it because it just felt like
i just i just felt a connection i just
wanted to know what a name was so there
was an
after party and after pie which i
actually wasn't invited to but i just
figured you know what
i'm sure if i turn up no one's gonna
know
so i went i went down to this aft party
afterwards i wasn't invited but i
thought
it'll be all right i'll just slip in see
if she's see if she's there
really crazy seven years ago today
exactly and
i opened the door to this little
community center
and i i was literally the only
white dude in the room okay so everybody
kind of looks and i'm like oh my
goodness they noticed
um so i'm feeling really awkward uh the
groom comes over and he's like hi samuel
you know looking a bit confused as to
why i'm there or how i got the address
i just followed up the other cars i'm
like oh man
i just wanted the world to swallow me up
why did i do this this is ridiculous
what was i thinking and he sort of says
you know hey you know come and help
yourself go
grab some some food so i'm standing in
the in the buffet
you know holding the plates for queuing
up to eat food and there and i
saw this lady tucked away in the far
corner of the room uh and i'm like okay
she's there
and at the time right now i had this
real strong desire
to get out of there i hadn't decided to
go and speak to her but i had
uh you know the little voice you know
you know um little voice that you get
you're crazy you shouldn't do this she's
probably got a boyfriend anyway
just turn back now um you know telling
me don't do it don't do it don't do it
you're crazy
and then i also had this little this
little desire to go and speak to her
and to just ask what her name was and
and it was that moment
where i was just deciding what should i
do well i just thought you know what
forget this who cares and i walked
across the room
and i was having to push past tables and
everything was really excuse me you know
excuse me can i get past
oh man in my head again i'm thinking
what am i doing what am i doing what am
i doing
i'm gonna get there and she's just gonna
be like hey i'm gonna be like hey and
then i'm gonna have to walk back
past everybody make a commotion and um
you know so i i just thought you know i
forget i'm gonna do this
and seven years ago today exactly i
walked over
and i met amanda i said where are you
from she said i'm from leeds
i'm born and bred i'm born and bred in
harare zimbabwe
but right now i'm
living in leeds i'm like that's crazy my
name
is leeds it's meant to be you know
anyway cut a long story short we went
out on a date
and nine months after this
day 5th of april january the 18th
we then had our african zimbabwean
wedding
and then in july that same year we had
our english traditional wedding
and you know even now
seven years later when i think back to
that day i can still very very very
clearly remember
i can very very very clearly remember
just thinking
i should just go home you know oh this
is this is awkward i should just leave
and now looking back i'm so glad that i
didn't
and sometimes when i'm you know we've
got three kids now we had a
jessica grace our newest addition to the
family
um six weeks ago we've got ruby who's
three
luke who's two and i just look at my
family who are like my everything
my wife amanda we've been married now
six years
known each other seven to this day
three kids and the home i mean this is
you know amanda found this amanda is
just my everything and i just think you
know what
um thank god i walked across the room
and had a little bit of courage on that
day
thank god i didn't listen to my little
voices
you know the the mind's job trying to
protect me
um from from looking stupid we spend so
much time caring about what other people
think
the very people that wouldn't even be at
our funeral
you know wouldn't even or if they were
they wouldn't even cry
and we spend that whole life trying to
please people and trying to
um impress people it doesn't matter
i mean ultimately i think the difference
between people that get what they want
in life whether that be financially
whether that be personally whatever it
might be are people that just grab the
opportunities
are people that don't listen to all the
reasons why not to do something
and just say thank you for sharing and
look at the reasons
why to do something that look at the
possibilities
what if instead of what if it goes wrong
what if it goes
right so i hope this oh sugar
um i hope this um
you know i hope this speaks to somebody
because maybe you're in a situation
right now in your life
and and this supplies this is a property
challenge thinking tell me why are you
telling me about how you met your wife
i don't care well it's because right now
april what is it april 5th april 5th of
course it is it's my 7 year
anniversary when we met um right now
like there's so many opportunities
that we can grab within the property
industry
personally in business investments i
mean i'll name a few for a start the
government
have been doing giving out so much
special
offer incentives right now bounce back
loans have just finished
bounce back loans finished a few days
ago and a bounce back loan you could
literally just
get a loan from the government or backed
by the government
for you know 50 grand pay no interest
for 12 months and then pay 2 interest
and not have to worry about paying it
back for 6 years
was it 7 years something like that
that's a long time
2 interest after a year but before that
free
and and at the time people were saying i
don't know if i need it i'm worried
i don't know and look at all the people
that are getting rich now off the back
of those
loans that the government were giving
out the stamp duty holiday
it's mg holiday so there's a lot of
incentives and i know
the government aren't perfect and
there's a lot of good and there's a lot
of bad and
it's a very complex issue but there are
opportunities on the table
you know no no now the bounce back
loan's been replaced by the recovery
loan
and the details of it haven't um
entirely come out
um but there's a lot of opportunities on
the table and it's about finding the
opportunities
and grabbing them rather than worrying
about the what-ifs
um i mean if i'd have worried about all
the what-ifs before going and speaking
to amanda well i did
i was thinking oh but what if you know
she's got a boyfriend already well what
if she's not
what if what if she thinks she's stupid
well why what happens if she doesn't why
if she likes you
most people in that moment will be
thinking about i might look silly or
this she
might get rejected i was thinking about
well
i might get married and and now i am i
know i'm in a beautiful house with three
kids and
the best family ever because i focused
on the
the good what if instead of the bad what
if you know i mean there's so many other
opportunities like hmos
if you buy a property now in a
non-article 4 area
as soon as it becomes an article 4 area
then you're going to have grandfather
rights planning permission
people just aren't realizing the
opportunities on the table
it's crazy i mean i've been saying
banging on about this for the last few
years
and it's also really interesting that
people only realize the opportunity once
it's gone
when i was out in the streets of london
and in hyde park a few days ago and i
was giving away a free house
not one person signed the the documents
for the free house
yet every single person that didn't sign
and missed out as the second
they'd missed out on the opportunity and
they realized that it was for real and
they
and they'd missed out they were like i
was about to do it i was about to do it
i almost did it there was a guy that
said if you've just given me five more
seconds everyone said that it was crazy
how many people if they'd have been
apparently given five more seconds
would have would have would have done
the deal and it's the same with the hate
with hmos it's the same with the fact
that
you can get a hmo without having to get
planning permission
and once article 4 comes in you won't be
able to do that
and you'll be denied getting hmo and
it's going to be a nightmare
and everyone's going to go i was about
to do it
you know i mean what about rent to rent
ever
right now it's such a brilliant time to
get rent to rent properties
why because landlords
a lot of their properties they can't
rent them out of service accommodation
because service accommodation
market might be tough in that particular
area look what me and david did
on the financial freedom challenge we
found a landlord
who had a student property he was really
struggling with it because the
universities are closed so we got the
really really good
deal on the property right now because
of the opportunity
but then in a few months time boom we've
got that property for years to come
making a nice monthly profit so there's
opportunities within the rent to rent
industry
there's opportunities everybody wants to
buy at the moment
but there's not enough properties around
all the investors are wanting to buy
investors are queuing up throwing money
at properties all right great
so why don't wha how about making the
most of packaging and selling deals
saying everyone wants to buy a deal
everything's closed apart from the
property market
you are allowed to go on viewings
the opportunity is is is ripe
you know you're allowed to go on
viewings right now everyone wants
properties
go on viewings package some deals and
sell them
online training if you're at home
if you're stuck at home but the
opportunity for online training is
immense
there's just so many opportunities to
better yourself samuel 365 by the way my
mentoring and training
platform is 95 pound a month so if
you're at home right now
and you aren't having to go to work or
you've got a bit more time
and you're at home well how about you
use the
the the situation to get trained up
so that when lockdown fully lifts boom
you're on fire
lease option agreements there's just so
many
opportunities red diamond moments
and i think the difference between
people who fly
in business and massively succeed and
those that don't
are are the successful people are the
people that
take the opportunities that come and the
unsuccessful people miss them
but then complain about it once it's
gone and i can just see right now in
2021
i can see so much opportunity i can see
so many people
not realizing the opportunities on the
table and they're going to go so on
april 5th
april 5th is the day of opportunity the
day that i learned my lesson
um when i met my wife and just walked
across the room walking across the room
changed my life forever
let that be a lesson to you and a
reminder to you to grab the
opportunities
that are on the table right now this
month
so if you enjoy my channel like
subscribe i share videos every single
day
around property investment with the only
agenda
to seeing you succeed in business in
life
and in property thanks for watching and
peace out